concerns are being raised that millions
of poor and underprivileged children in
india
are at risk of being forced into child
labor due to the coronavirus pandemic
child welfare organizations in the
country are sounding the alarm
at a time when significant numbers of
jobs have been lost in india's
informal sector during lockdowns the
fear is
children of out-of-work parents could be
trafficked
to fill the gap here's more on a crisis
that could erase
decades of progress made in combating
child labor
down with child trafficking boys and
girls learn through play with child
welfare advocate rockesh singer
child trafficking is a daily reality in
india
children are sometimes kidnapped others
are forced by their parents to work
fifteen-year-old nuja parveen has just
returned from visiting relatives in the
countryside
how to defend themselves for years he
has been working with a charity group to
fight child trafficking
he says the pandemic has made the
situation even worse
children are in great demand as a form
of cheap labor
when adult migrant workers returned to
their villages
demand for cheap labor increased child
labor is used
to compensate since the schools are
closed due to the lockdown
parents have been sending their children
away to work
this child laborer was found during a
raid on a bakery in delhi
15 boys were rescued from restaurant
kitchens and workshops
in recent months the foundation has
freed more than one thousand children
being held in slavery-like conditions
signs of worsening poverty on the
streets of delhi
child beggars existed even before the
pandemic
but now millions of middle class indians
have lost their jobs and laid off their
servants
these children are helping to feed their
families
kailash satyarthi has established a
children's foundation
which has grown into a nationwide
network its mission
raising awareness among indians about
the need for child welfare
the biggest threat is that millions of
children may fall back into
slavery trafficking child labour child
marriages
school would be denied
these children walk along the train
tracks in delhi
they hope to earn money from selling
plastic bottles
according to unicef there are more than
10 million child laborers in india
most younger than nine years old
that's why rakesh singer has invited
mothers to this event he stresses the
importance of sending children to school
he encourages the boys and girls to
demand a good education
the school was not good at all it didn't
even have water
we wrote to the head and complained
about the lack of water
we even spoke to city council members
about it
i've come here to help find a solution
a school play shows what it's like for
many poor children
how they're drugged and kidnapped
but these children are learning where
they can turn to for help
[Applause]
and joining us for more is mr dhananjay
tingle he's executive director
of the child rights ngo bajpun bachao
andolan
mr tingle your organization claims to
have rescued more than a thousand
children
from exploitative conditions in the last
few months isn't this a job the
government should be doing
this is true but the rescue operations
which have been done
we have done it with the support of the
government only
and because you cannot do a rescue and
you cannot stop or chilling from
any any vehicle cannot be stopped
without the permission without the
involvement of the government so we have
been doing it along with the government
uh surely the identification has been
done by us we have identified
more than about 1200 children we have
rescued in last uh since the lockdown
has started and from first april i can
see that
we have rescued around 1200 children uh
and in last one month one and a half
month the children who were being
trafficked back to work from
behar we have rescued more than 300
children
such children with information we got
from our teams in working in that
source districts from where the children
were coming and
previously the chilean we found the
chilean working during the
lockdown also there were the industries
in which they were they were staying
inside they were working
some of the children were stuck up they
were trafficked
the work has stopped trafficking stopped
giving them food and all that they had
no money nothing
so those kind of children also were
rescued who were the basically the
victims of trafficking and they were
facing problems
so it's a work of the government and
government supported us in
uh rescuing it and that is your right
but
government has been with us right
you're talking about uh these children
who've been working in exploitative
conditions
but i'd just like to know for you uh
from you for about
migrant laborers who already are
struggling to make
ends meet i wonder if they really have
any other option
than to put all available hands
including their children
to work
uh that is true the conditions because
obvious the children were
being trafficked from the source
district was because of the poverty
in the in those districts that was the
reason
now when all the migrants have gone back
the conditions have become even worse in
the
villages we have rescued some children
who are working in the
who have been trafficked for bengal
industry
and while talking to one of them they
said it very clearly that they
my father is alex shapola i'm supposed
to be he's
and we have five brothers and sisters
what do we do about it
i was studying in the school but i have
to leave
and when the trafficker came and said
you know when father offered that he
said he would like to go but
jafika said no they want a child who's
with the nimble fingers
and so he has to be he has to come
though he wanted to study
but he has to come so the conditions in
the villages have become really very
very bad
and uh people when they left from
uh during the lockdown they vowed that
they will not be coming back to work
right now you can imagine when they're
coming back the conditions have been
worse than they're locked on
and they're back in the villages right
but the problem continues and i suppose
the root question really is
what needs to happen to prevent children
from being
exploited for work
see india uh india luckily have one of
the best welfare schemes
available but rna is that those
schemes are not reaching to the people
we have our models in which we have used
uh we call it the ball with gram model
which we work for prevention of
child labor and child trafficking we
successfully did it in those areas where
the children were
either that there was a rampant
trafficking or the allah working
was just access of the government
services to the people
and that was good enough for them to
withdraw the children from work and put
them into school and stop
stop the children and not sending the
children to work
so government issue proactive in
providing the social welfare schemes
to the in the villages education system
schools teachers needs to be improved
the school systems needs to be improved
we are talking of uh teachers coming
into the village school teaching
there's one teacher who is teaching all
the classes from one to five there's
just one teacher teaching there's no
other teacher
and he is also being used for the work
so these are the systems which we need
to improve in the villages
and if we are able to do that then i'm
sure that trafficking will automatically
stop
but it has to come from appropriately
from the government machinery and the
government people
right improvement of the grassroots
level is what you are saying thank you
so much for speaking to us
executive director of the child rights
ngo bachmann bachawan dolan
you